事業目的への共感[音楽]
が弱い人は育てられないです。人頭の悪い
上司に部下をつけるという[音楽]のは
それは会社自体が頭が悪いんですよ。必ず
結果の出せる人間にメンバーを配属する。
青木サの人生警額100回聞いたら豊かに
なる話。
今回はですね、まずは新人教育を任せてはいけない人の特徴について教えていただけますでしょうか?それはね、いい加減のやつだよ。そしてそれはある意味でひなはよく親取りから学ぶって言うじゃない。だからやっぱり新人は最初についた上司。
[鼻息]
ま、それも中堅のね、上司の教えが最初に
入るんですよ。だから基準の低い人間や
会社の事業目的に対する[音楽]
共感の弱い人間は絶対向いてません。会社
の理念、会社のビジョン、経営方針、そう
いうものをしっかりと伝えられる人じゃ
ないとダメです。それと俺はこう考えるで
はなくて、我が社の方針は我が社の大切に
していることはというそういういわゆる
ホアザチームそういうマインドを持った人
が向いてるのでその真逆の俺が俺がの
いわゆるそういうパワーニーズの強い
タイプはやっぱり人を育てずに結果的に
自己概念下げてしまっ
あとあの曖昧な思考からは曖昧な結果しか
生まれないので新人ってまだまだ知識が
足りないので曖昧な指導しかできない人間
ダめです。すごいやる気にさせたように
見えるんだけど、すぐパッションダウンを
起こしちゃうんですよ、メンバーって。
その反対にその具体的に目標達成の手順、
方法、内容、具体的に指導してもらえる人
の下に着くと別にそのパッション、情熱、
熱意を持って取り組んでなかったようだ
けれども、達成がモチベーションを維持さ
せる。うん。
そういうところが大事なとこじゃないかな。うん。
ありがとうございます。
ちなみにこう今の話を聞いて、ま、
月に、ま、多くの会社は新人を受け入れていくと思うんですけれども、新人の教育担当ちょっといい加減な人しかいないなとか、なんかちょっとこう、ま、曖昧な指導、具体的な指導ができるって言うと、ま、ちょっとどうかなっていう、こうことが顔に頭に思い浮かんだ時になんかそのうん、
[咳払い]
え、育成担当を再度教育できるのか、それとも他の手を取った方がいいのか、どうしたらいいですかね。うん。
基本的にはね、えっと、まず会社として
システム、教育とシステムっていう両輪が
大事なんだけれども、あの、うちはどうし
てるかとね、アチューメントどうしてる
かっていうと、毎週マインド教育してん
ですよ。毎週月曜日は全体のその情報共有
とホ技チームなので、みんなのそのやる
べきことやそれから先週1週間それから
これからのことに関する情報の共有だけで
はなくて私が必ず30分ぐらいはその
マインドセットをしてますよね。あとうち
の全役員が一言ずつ言ってマインドセット
してる。じゃあ、ノーハウはどうなの
かって言うと、実は現場でマニュアルを
整備させている。で、そのマニュアルを
覚えさせる。後等で先輩が伝えるという
とこにはばらつきが出るのでマニュアルの
クオリティを高めてそのマニュアル通りに
指導する。あとは技術に関してはまだ十分
じゃないので同行してその指導をする。
現場で指導する。ここで気をつけなきゃ
いけないのは能力の低い人にメンバーを
つけちゃいけないんです。必ず結果の
出せる人間にメンバーを配属する。うん。
ま、そういう人がいない場合には、ま、
会社として最も優秀な人負荷がかかるかも
しれないけど県でやってもらうようにした
方がいいんじゃないかと私は思いますよ。
ありがとうございます。
青木社長自身もあのおそらくその本当にですね、最初の頃はずっとこう新人教育っていうところにも力を入れてこられたと思うんですけれども新人教育で
番社長が大切にされてこられたことってなんかありますか?
やっぱりさっき言ったようにマインドセットでしょ。
まず4つの地震、会社に対する地震、商品
に対する自信、職業に対する自信、そして
自分に対する自信、この4つの自信を
ピカピカにしてあげられるようにサポート
をするということを僕はいつも意識してき
ました。あとなんだろう、自分が出来
にやれと言わないってことだよね。だから
基本的には率戦っていう言葉があるんだ
けど、新人指導に必要なのは戦犯
です。私は常に現場で人を育ててきました
。ま、今でもそれは変わらないですね。
ですから毎週必ず
はメッセージするでしょ。ま、そういう
ことですよね。ありがとうございます。
ちなみに最後にもう1
点だっけ?なんかもしそのなんか中堅の社員でその新人指導に対してちょっとまが残るなっていう人がいた時にもし青木社長だったらどういうフィードバックするかってちょっとお聞かせいただいてもいいんですか?
ま、具体的にどんなあの課題があるの?その人は
例えばですけれども、ま、ちょっとこう仕事の基準が緩いとかあるいはその指導の仕方がどちらかというとこう具体的ではなくってちょっと曖昧で頑張ろうっていうこう気持ちだけセットアップするようなの人がいた場合で
ま、まるまる君ね、今実際新人のこう育成
を任せてるけど、どうその成長のレベルっ
てどんな風に自分自身捉えている?
マインドセット、さらには具体的な
ノーハウナッジ、必要な知識をちゃんと
伝えてる。あと技術はどうと、え、実際の
ところ今僕は客観的に見ててちょっと具体
性にかけてるんじゃないかなと。こな間だ
新人のこと話したら僕が捉えているある
この期間で成長するレベルまでまだ至って
いなかったね。やっぱ曖昧な思考からは
曖昧な結果しか出ないので、具体的に
もっと指導するようにちょっとプランを
立ててこれから3ヶ月どんな風に指導する
のかちょっと僕に提案してくれるという風
にして思考と行為を一致させるように
アジャストだよね。調整すると思います。
でも頭が悪いとすぐにはね、変わらないん
だよ。分かる。だからもうそれはこっちの
人線が悪いわけ。はっきり言うと。うん。
やっぱりね、曖昧な思考からは曖昧な結果
しか出ないっていうのは僕の口癖なんだ
けど、頭の悪い上司に部下をつけるという
のは、それは会社自体が頭が悪いんですよ
。分かる。これちょっとシビアな言葉なん
だけど、頭のいい悪いはどこに出るかって
言うと、具体性と目標達成に対する
こだわりで出てくるんです。だから
なるべく
目標達成できる人間に多くの優秀な人間を
配属する。これが秘訣だと思います。2割
の人で8割の成果なんですよ。全体の8割
で2割しか生み出さないんです。
で、この2割の人で8割の成果、その優秀
な人にさらに優秀な人を配属する。これが
成功の秘訣です。みんな逆やるのよ。いや
、あまり結果が出てないから彼のとこに
優秀な人間つけてね、結果出るように
サポートしてやろうとか。だからみんな
うまくいかないんですよ。なぜなら下の
人間が嫌かんでちゃうんですよ。そんな
能力の低い上司の下に配属されると私は
そこはちょっとね、昔から違うと思います
。だから成果が出続けてるんだと。
そうですね。だからまず会社には事業目的
があるので、その事業目的への共感が弱い
人は
育てられないです人を。としてあとは
やっぱり曖昧な思考から曖昧な結果しか出
ないので、そのロジカルシンキングね、
つまり目標達成から逆算して具体的な手順
方法内容をしっかりとそれも毎日しっかり
と指導できるようなそういう決めの細かい
厳格な人が向いているわけだからその真逆
は任しちゃいけない。ま、掃じて目標達成
できない人には新人を育成を任せてはいけ
ないとこういうことになるのかな。あ、
是非ね、ま、ちょうど4月本当に新卒がね
、どんどん入ってきて、ま、うちも
、え、新卒と中途と入れると30名ほどの
ね、人が入ってきますから、ま、そこ
[鼻息]はやっぱり職教育が1番大事な時
なので、ま、集中して、え、最初の3ヶ月
間徹底的に指導してあげることが大事だと
思いますから、頑張ってください。え、
是非ね、今日私のコメント、あの、
メッセージを聞いて何かコメントがあれば
コメントお願いします。え、あとハイプも
ね、[音楽]是非応援してください。あと
は、あの、え、まだチャンネル登録して
ない人はね、是非あのチャンネル登録の方
も協力してくれると嬉しいです。頑張り
ます。皆さんいい人生を行きましょう。
ありがとうございます。また次回の
YouTubeで会いましょう。